Let's illustrate the Fast Fourier
Transform scheme by looking
at the case where N = 4.
That means omega = i, and
we want to evaluate our polynomial
at the points 1, i, -1, and -i.
Recall that we use our
even-odd decomposition.
And that we recycle as much of
the computation as possible.
Here I've written out
the four needed sub-problems.
Thus, we've reduced the problem of
computing A at the 4th root subunity
to computing Ae and
Ao at the second root subunity.
Plus some effort to combine the results.
To compute Ae and Ao,
at the second roots of unity,
we apply the same strategy again.
First writing them in
terms of the even and
odd sub-polynomials and then recycling
as much of the computation as possible.
Each of the two previous problems
has been reduced to evaluating
an order one polynomial at one point.
But this is trivial since it
only involves the constant term.
The upward pass of the recursion then
fills in all these intermediate values,
eventually giving us the values of
A at the fourth roots of unity.